[Music]
now we're your world heavyweight biggest
Tony in the city dude what's up new
episode most expensive it's all about
winners today and I'm your host 2 Chainz
if you woke up this morning you win it
and today you're going up with the pros
me and my boy Tiger will be looking at
the UFC Performance Institute
state-of-the-art the world's largest
vibrator after hitting the heart you may
need a good rubdown so my people here
what body friend has a solution for that
with a Lamborghini inspired massage
chair now give you the keys this has
keys what in the world is it and you
know I stay winning so we're gonna get
competitive with wormwood one of the
upper echelon sand gaming tables those
tables don't have hand wheels no yeah
that's solid cast iron right this is the
most expensive this winners true
[Music]
what's up man how you doing I'm Chinese
pleasure for here take it very tonight
you guys
what made you have superformance instead
[Music]
thank you for being here without you
before man yeah once upon a time it's
been a minute you still love it oh I
still love it I love telling people to
fight more than I now love fighting all
right and is it that easy for people
that's watching no it used to be easier
I couldn't even compete today I
understand so but I didn't have a
facility like this this is sort of have
this place back in the back I want to
see what you got you know I'm saying me
and Tycho been in the gym you know I'm
saying show me my dog
[Music]
so I'll run on this I'll run about also
the trans now oh yeah
and so the reason there's the jet is the
jet keeps you from achieving despair
every time you bounce up and pushes you
back to have to run together like stay
low yeah well you just run the smart
people to work it can do data analysis
to make sure that you're running
correctly so I got my trainer here with
me my boy Cesar he he couldn't wait to
take his shirt off I wouldn't even own
shirt but boy I got my boy his cz no sir
oh there we go
go ahead and step in cuz I didn't want
to take my shirt off the day you feel
like embarrassing y'all may feel like
way feel like [ __ ] Yolo I would I
would take my shirt off but I think all
my hair will clog though oh okay
interesting problem with this man and
they even look at his foresee that was
wonderful man no this is about a four
hundred thousand and we had to get a guy
from Germany come over and put it in for
us so this is just four hundred thousand
there's not bit of kiddie pools
y'all make injuries look damn Neku
[Music]
all right so we're gonna cut some force
play testing each one of these first
place costs about a hundred grams but
butts actually expensive is to get
people to come out and put them in and
then the software which they run off of
he's also really expensive is another
ten or fifteen for the software for each
rack
he's our markoulis motion capture so i
measures speed and velocity right so for
us it doesn't really matter necessarily
if you move five hundred pounds it
matters how fast you can move your
weight plus your body weight as fast as
possible right this calls a hundred
thousand this this is the are you deep
heads one are you deep jump lands
break it down for uh oh come on in so so
the look at the force in his left leg
your left leg was stronger than the
right because he's right-handed 60
centimeters it's about average good left
foot jumper yes yeah little you to see
science I could beat that got lost did
ever with Mary Poppins and how much is
this machine again let's say hundred
grands - that's impressive with all the
extra weight I do this [ __ ]
what's your neighbors cooking over there
hey I'd like a pull-up model let out a
jury on any guy house gosh Chuck you
gotta climb on network
[Music]
tygo you came look over bring your chin
over and see what's going on you're not
really doing a strict pull-ups we caught
huh Pam cooking some chicken